bring in the New Year like a gangster in
the underground at the Mob Museum we
have with us bartender Paul stillmack
and he's here to tell us all about the
big party they're having in some of the
amazing cocktails they have I want to
get to this in a minute because this
truly I have so many questions but
welcome to the show
fantastic to be here yeah we've got a
fantastic bit to talk about the
underground Speakeasy has a wonderful
wonderful cocktail program that features
a lot of great drinks but we also have
an award-winning Distillery now that's
amazing because I've heard so much about
the Moonshine there and you have your
own line and we're going to talk about
that but tell us a little bit about the
underground what's the whole vibe there
so it's a Prohibition era Speakeasy
cocktail bar and we're located right
underneath the Mob Museum which is
actually the national museum of
organized crime and law enforcement
right here in downtown Las Vegas so it's
just off Fremont Street it's as easy as
taking the downtown Loop or the big bus
it drops you off right there and we're
in the basement all you need is a
password to get in right on the side
door we're open every day from noon
until 10 o'clock on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday we're open from noon until
midnight on a Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday and we even have live music going
on oh my gosh you have everything and
let's talk about some of the cocktails
you're gonna actually whip up a cocktail
that you guys uh it's like your
specialty it's called bee's knees yeah
so we got our little take on a pro
ambition classic the bee's knees this is
one of the most popular drinks from back
during prohibition now what's in this so
we are using a strawberry infused gin oh
you had me at strawberry I'm all in
already okay we got a jalapeno infused
honey that we make in-house do you know
all my favorite ingredients the jalapeno
no well the cool thing about this
jalapeno honey is it's not too spicy so
everybody can enjoy it even if you're
not like super into hot stuff okay
really nice well-balanced drink we got
that together we're gonna throw some ice
right in here and give this guy a shake
I love it this is just one of the
specialty cocktails that you can enjoy
there the Disney
and as soon as we give this a taste
we're going to talk about really really
what you guys are famous for this looks
delicious oh my gosh
and people can get this and so we are
serving this every day from noon when we
open up until 10 o'clock this is
beautiful look at that wow or until
midnight on the weekends if you come in
on Friday Saturday Sunday we got live
music going on oh that's so good oh my
gosh I love that I can taste all those
flavors you were talking about let's
talk about this so we also make
award-winning moonshine we've got a
couple different styles here for you
we've got our regular 100 proof
moonshine made from 100 corn we got 100
Proof cinnamon moonshine but here for
the holidays we got our special limited
edition peppermint moonshine and it
clocks in at 100 proof but it doesn't
drink like it's 100 Proof that's what
I'm worried about actually but that's a
good thing right yeah that's a great
thing for me now tell us tell us a
little bit about moonshine and what it
is I think some people just picture
people making in their bathtubs right
yeah so a lot of people have
misconceptions about moonshine what it
essentially is is before it becomes
whiskey it is an unaged spirit so this
is 100 corn whiskey that's simply on age
and you can buy it at and you can buy it
at the mom Museum you can also there's
purchase options available through our
website at
www.themobmuseum.org but what's really
cool is we have this newest member of
our family The Goodfellas vanilla
moonshine this one's a little bit lower
proof than the 100 Proof so this one is
really easy to sip on whether you like
it hot cold in your coffee you know
first thing in the morning